and welcome to another episode of for
adults oh my god
yeah I see you max this is me this is
why I call you honey you know I was okay
I could see I see
[Laughter]
well you need a change okay good good
good good
he's a blue cup like that that you just
got but she was down this way as well he
was like a little TV room I come on come
on come out come out wherever you are
list of the Mac that means Tom what Tom
thing for me
no I think you should sing a song Tom
sing the song Tom talk to you this is
eval you're so evil right now I don't
suck go find me you'll never get me so
stupid all right max found me max found
me
my feelings my checking a condiment us
at the moment I'm twerking twerking I
found
I know keeps you in the boxes and you'll
get me eventually I think Fred should
avoid
anyway no wait you sweet devil [ __ ] you
know what happened when you see the
grenade over there through the wall and
I bounce back and I was the only
surviving box baby that's what you're
meaning oh my god ever
IRA's I hope you enjoyed this episode as
always having a lot of fun playing so
let me know if you want more hit
subscribe to come over today leave a
like if you enjoyed watching I'll see
you in the next one stay awesome love
you
[Music]